The pandemic is adding another
layer of difficulty to life in Gaza.
Vaccination uptake remains sluggish among the
territory's 2 million inhabitants, and as DW
Middle-East correspondent Tania Kraemer reports
from Gaza City, COVID-19 is further straining an
already weak health system at a time the economy
is struggling and people are trying to rebuild.
Here in the center of
Gaza-City, in Al-Wahde Street,
workers are still clearing the
rubble of a residential building,
destroyed in the conflict between Israel and Hamas
in May - one of the several continuing crises.
A few blocks away, Dr. Shadi Awad and his team
have been fighting the coronavirus-pandemic
at Gaza's largest hospital: Al-Shifa Hospital.
This ward is dedicated to testing and treating
patients suspected of having a COVID-19
infection. While the number of seriously
ill patients has slightly decreased in
recent days, infection rates remain high.
"We used to categorize these cases in people
who could be sent home and treated at home,
and cases who were admitted
and treated in hospital:
Some were sent to intensive care. We've
been in this latest wave of the pandemic for
a month. It has been the biggest and most intense
wave since the beginning of the pandemic in Gaza."
The staff are exhausted, the doctor says. Over
1500 people have died of COVID-19 in Gaza.
The pandemic has further strained an
already weak health system and dire economy.
The small territory, ruled
by the militant group Hamas,
has been effectively cut off by Israel
and Egypt for the past decade.??
Although scarce in the beginning, vaccines
have become increasingly available,
but more people need to take them.
"Still we will work with the community
and help the authorities here to spread
the facts and the safety of the vaccine
and to encourage people to get the vaccine.
At the moment, Gaza has reached 40 percent of
vaccination among the targeted population."
Roughly 1.2 million out of Gaza's 2 million
inhabitants are eligible to get a jab at
a vaccination center like this one.
Authorities have made vaccinations
mandatory for certain categories of
people - such as those working with the
public. However, reactions are mixed:
"In Gaza, there are a lot of problems,
it's very crowded. There is a lot of mixing
in the workplace, schools, among
students, even with the elderly.
Our society is very closely linked
so vaccination is very important. I
took the first and second doses of the Sputnik
vaccine and now they sent us the third dose."
"Here, people are generally not that concerned
about taking precautionary measures. They
don't care about Corona that much anymore.
I feel that people are just going along
with things, so COVID is not affecting
them like it did before.  Maybe the most
important thing is the economic situation."
While the pandemic continues
to weigh on daily life,
it is just one of the several ongoing
crises people have to deal with in Gaza.